Traductor: Laura Heredia Abolafio
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
¿Os habéis dado cuenta de cómo se parecen
las palabras 'aula' y 'jaula'?
He pasado la mayor parte
de mi vida en ellas, en aulas me refiero.
Me apasiona el aprendizaje
y me apasiona la enseñanza,
aunque es fuera del aula
donde más he aprendido.
Al terminar la carrera de publicidad,
aquí en Málaga,
la curiosidad me llevó
en velero a Inglaterra
y de ahí, el amor me llevó a Japón.
Me enamoré instantáneamente del país,
de la cultura, aprendí el idioma,
me saqué otro máster,
encima en japonés,
me casé y tuvimos dos maravillosos hijos.
Sin experiencia
en el trabajo que me surgió,
pronto aprendí lo mucho que me gustaría.
Durante diez años, fui maestro de inglés,
principalmente en preescolar y primaria.
Los niños me enseñaron muchísimo.
Para cuando tuve a los míos propios,
había tenido bastantes ocasiones
de experimentar
con los niños de los demás.
Lo que quedaba claro es lo muchísimo
que se subestima
las capacidades de los peques.
Hay un potencial enorme malgastado.
Empecé a experimentar
con mis hijos inmediatamente
y el entorno natural
parecía un buen sitio para comenzar.
La montaña siempre
ha sido una gran maestra.
Nos enseñó compañerismo,
tenacidad, y amor por la naturaleza.
Nos enseñó cómo planificar
y cuándo improvisar.
La montaña también nos abriría
las puertas a descubrir más del mundo.
Viendo el progreso físico, mental y
espiritual de mis hijos en la naturaleza,
esos eran mis mentores
y yo no era quién para negar su sabiduría.
Como ejemplos tempranos
de nuestras aventuras, el monte Fuji.
[Fuji 3776 m]
Mi hijito con tres años,
lo subió en tiempo récord y sin lágrimas.
El pico del Teide.
Al verano siguiente con cuatro añitos,
también lo subió en tiempo récord
y hasta volvimos corriendo a la vuelta.
Los niños sabemos que todo es posible
y nos dejamos guiar por el corazón.
Lo que había comenzado como un paseo
por el bosque, nos llevó a los montes,
de una montaña a otras, de cima en cima
y de maravilla en maravilla,
hemos recorrido
más de 40 países hasta el día de hoy.
Pero hay una raíz oscura
en esta historia también.
Mientras mi primer hijo de dos meses
yacía inocente frente a la ventana,
merecedor de heredar un planeta sano,
tal y como lo habían hecho
casi todas las generaciones anteriores,
al otro lado del cristal,
a solamente 200 km,
se desenlazaba uno de los eventos
más devastadores de la historia humana:
el gran terremoto del este de Japón.
Un evento natural,
tal y como fue el tsunami que lo siguió.
La gran pérdida de vidas fue
una tragedia terrible y quizás inevitable.
Sin embargo, la catástrofe
que causó el tsunami,
el derrame radioactivo
de la planta nuclear de Fukushima,
eso sí fue creado por el hombre
y vamos a tener que vivir
con las consecuencias para una eternidad.
Más allá de este evento,
el hecho de que
el reactor fuera siquiera necesario
era para satisfacer
nuestras necesidades consumistas.
Quizás sea un poco duro decirlo así,
pero indirectamente yo me sentía culpable,
me sentía responsable.
Como comprenderéis,
estaba enfadado, estaba decepcionado.
Era difícil no encontrar contradicciones
en nuestras acciones diarias,
acciones que alimentan la máquina
y que dañan el planeta.
Reflexioné sobre
el estado de la naturaleza
y el papel de la educación
para formar a la siguiente generación.
Me replanteé nuestros hábitos
de sociedad consumista
y cuál es nuestra responsabilidad
individual en todo esto,
Como sabéis, muchas son las catástrofes
medioambientales en el mundo
y lo triste es que reaccionamos
solamente cuando nos toca de cerca.
Lo más triste es que
la mayoría se encierran en la negación
y hay un peligro
de que esté pasando a nivel global.
Me sentí incapaz de seguir contribuyendo
al deterioro de la naturaleza.
Durante demasiado tiempo
había participado en un esquema
que no me convencía del todo,
pero no conocía alternativas
y vivía cómodamente.
Una vez que nacieron mis hijos
era incapaz de transmitirles valores
en los que no creyera.
Personalmente no supe qué hacer,
excepto minimizar mi impacto.
Minimizar el consumo
es una idea difícil de vender,
pero es uno de los valores principales
con los que educo a mis hijos.
No es un sacrificio.
Explícaselo a la familia en Navidades.
Reciclar está bien, reusar está bien.
Pero el rey es rechazar.
Nada supera el simplemente consumir menos.
Con un sentido de urgencia,
como si cada día fuera el último
quise que mis hijos conocieran a la
Madre Tierra mientras seguía aún con vida
y que sintieran
la realidad de su unión con ella,
que la amaran y que la protegieran.
Su generación se va a tener que encargar
de limpiar y arreglar el desastre
que les estamos dejando de herencia.
Varios fueron los años
de asimilación y de batallas internas,
hasta que un buen día, guiado
por el corazón y sin ningún tipo de plan,
dimos un salto al vacío.
Abandoné la seguridad
de mi trabajo estable,
abandoné mi vida social,
abandoné un sinfín de bienes materiales
de los que ni me acuerdo ni me importan,
abandoné un futuro seguro y estable
por lo inesperado.
Desde que dejamos Japón,
rumbo a Nueva Zelanda y más allá,
la vida nómada con mis dos pequeños,
de tres y cinco años entonces,
y por tramos con mi esposa, está siendo
un camino de continuo aprendizaje.
Quizás estéis pensando que sea rico,
que tenga dinero...
La verdad es que no.
Cogí los pocos ahorros que tenía
e intenté sacarles el máximo de provecho.
Nuestras expediciones montañistas
nos habían preparado
para vivir con pocos recursos.
Años atrás viajamos como la mayoría:
hoteles, restaurantes,
atracciones turísticas.
No solamente salía caro,
sino que faltaba la conexión con el sitio.
Simplemente era otro artículo de consumo.
Ahora buscaba la conexión:
convivir con la gente local,
compartir historias, aprender.
El transporte público y los supermercados
nos servirían como los demás.
Conocimos a otros viajeros
y sus experiencias.
Cuando era necesario
acceder a zonas más remotas,
comprábamos un vehículo
que luego revendíamos.
A veces hasta ganamos, otras aprendimos.
Con fondos suficientes para gasolina,
comida y una tienda de campaña o dos,
teníamos autonomía total.
Teníamos tiempo y espacio para permitir
el desarrollo natural de nuestros hijos.
Sin distracciones
superfluas y comerciales,
lo aprendido durante el día se retiene
con mucha más facilidad y profundidad.
Una vez más, menos es más.
Visitamos a viejos amigos
y en ocasiones, hicimos wwoofing,
donde a cambio de ayudar
con las labores necesarias
uno recibe alimentación
y se puede hospedar.
Existen otras organizaciones
que ofrecen servicios parecidos.
Hicimos nuevas amistades,
aprendimos sobre jardinería,
repoblación de bosques,
vida en la granja.
Qué cosas más divertidas
para los niños, ¿verdad?
Para los jóvenes de entre 18 y 30 años,
está la posibilidad
de un visado Working Holiday,
que permite trabajar legalmente
mientras estás de viaje.
Nuestras estancias
en ciudades y poblados eran cortas,
principalmente para visitar
lugares de interés,
hacer las compras
e ir a la biblioteca.
Las bibliotecas ofrecen una ocasión única
para encontrar publicaciones locales,
mapas y libros infantiles
que no hay en otros sitios.
Además, hay wifi.
Adaptándonos gradualmente
a vivir con menos,
hemos estado deambulando por media Europa
en nuestra muy humilde furgoneta
o visto de otra forma,
muy lujosa tienda de campaña.
Si os dijera con lo poco
que se puede vivir.
Fueron los mejores años de mi vida.
Dormí bajo las estrellas, seguí la Luna
a lo largo de su paseo nocturno,
despertar con el canto de los pájaros,
el olor de los bosques
después de la lluvia.
El peligro, nuestra fiel compañera.
Aunque nunca mostró su cara,
gracias a nuestros amigos y guardianes.
Viajeros y locales de todas las edades,
ricos y pobres, familias,
surferos, moteros, camioneros, caminantes,
almas libres, feriantes, artistas, amantes
y agentes de la ley.
Nuestros amigos y maestros
se encuentran repartidos por el mundo.
Allá donde haya tierra y personas,
es nuestro hogar.
Museos y palacios son algunas
de las habitaciones de nuestra casa.
Nuestra ola son las montañas y el mar,
ríos y lagunas, desiertos y las junglas.
Nuestra ola es las calles de Katmandú
y los mercados de Estambul,
los vastos cielos de Mongolia,
los templos de Tíbet
y de la antigüedad griega.
Sin prejuicios, dejamos
que el lugar cuente su propia historia.
Hemos encontrado el hueco de aprender
el ajedrez, el backgammon, surakarta
manejar las matemáticas,
entender la química, la astronomía,
la geografía, historia,
leer y escribir
en inglés, castellano y japonés,
e incluso amaestrar los Legos
y tocar un poco el piano.
Por encima de esto, sentimos el mundo:
sus olores, sabores y dulces melodías.
Se aprende con todos los sentidos.
Educar y aprender van más allá
de esquemas rígidos y predeterminados.
Es un proceso natural y orgánico.
Comprimimos información en libros
y la difundimos en un número
de espacios habilitados para ello
que llamamos "escuelas".
Traemos otros mundos dinámicos y vivos
a un espacio neutro
y con poca involucración personal.
Para mí, una de las carencias principales
que tienen las escuelas
es la falta de movilidad.
¿Acaso aprendemos en ellas cosas
que no podemos adquirir de otra forma?
Diría que el problema no se haya
en la capacidad de los educadores,
sino en el marco educativo,
que es limitador y obsoleto.
Años de escolarización,
televisión y normalización
suprimen muchas de nuestras cualidades
innatas para encajar en un perfil deseado.
Somos socializados y moldeados.
El individuo se convierte en masa.
Como maestro, he visto este proceso
repetirse demasiadas veces.
¿Qué pasaría
si nos planteamos lo contrario?
Llevar el proceso de aprendizaje al sitio
mismo donde están ocurriendo los hechos,
donde se hizo historia.
Sumergirnos, y formar parte
de la dinámica misma.
Incluir nuestra narrativa.
No hace falta irse
a la otra punta del planeta.
Lo podemos hacer
en nuestro propio entorno.
Solo es cuestión de buscar con otros ojos.
Todos nacemos iluminados.
Cada pequeñín es un genio.
Un potencial salvador del planeta.
Único e irrepetible.
Sin prejuicios. Por eso,
los niños sabemos que todo es posible.
Cada individuo nace con una solución única
y en lugar de aprender de ello,
lo rechazamos e implantamos
nuestras viejas plantillas.
Cada cultura con la suya.
Educar no es repetir el pasado,
es crear el futuro.
El fundamento sobre el cual
evolucionamos como humanidad.
Los niños observamos y sentimos,
y según el mundo que nos rodea,
formamos nuestras ideas.
Vamos a darles una perspectiva amplia.
Por lo general, los niños somos capaces
de mucho más de lo que se nos permite.
Démosles una oportunidad.
Propongo lo siguiente:
Evitar la comodidad
para desarrollar capacidad de adaptación
y mantener la serenidad de la mente.
No evitar los riesgos.
Más vale quemarse el dedo con una vela,
a desconocer la fuerza del fuego.
Entrar en contacto directo
con el origen del conocimiento
y ser actor en lugar de espectador.
Son los intereses
y necesidades individuales
los que marcan el progreso.
Por esto y otros motivos, muchas familias
se plantean otros métodos de educación.
Entre estos, el home-schooling
es el más prevalente.
Estos métodos alternativos
están en auge a nivel mundial
y, en el caso del home-schooling,
los alumnos suelen tener un rendimiento
académico superior a la media escolar.
No hay un método específico.
Cada familia se plantea el proceso
según sus necesidades,
según sus posibilidades
y su forma de pensar.
Aunque educar a los hijos
a tiempo completo,
no es algo que todos podamos hacer.
Requiere de conocimientos básicos
y de muchísima motivación.
Requiere que estemos
permanentemente aprendiendo
para apoyar el desarrollo
de nuestros hijos
y proveerles
del contexto adecuado para ello.
Requiere de paciencia y, sobre todo,
requiere de amor incondicional.
La educación va más allá
de aulas y de escuelas.
Es también nuestra responsabilidad.
La nueva generación
es todo lo que tenemos.
De su educación, su forma de pensar y
su actitud, claramente, depende el futuro.
Es fundamental que los niños crezcan
con una conciencia global y hábitos sanos.
Hay muchísima gente maravillosa,
haciendo cosas increíbles,
conectando a personas,
creando oportunidades
para reconectar con la naturaleza.
No oiréis muchas de estas historias
en los medios, pero son abundantes
y a todos ellos estamos muy agradecidos.
La verdad es que somos unos novatos.
Acabamos de emprender este camino
y no sabemos exactamente
hacia dónde vamos.
Errores ha habido y muchos otros habrá,
pero descubrimientos también.
Nos gustaría estar más involucrados
y participar en proyectos colaborativos.
Siempre abiertos a seguir aprendiendo
y dispuestos a ayudar.
Todos tenemos algo que aportar.
Tú y yo nos somos iguales.
Lo bello es que somos distintos
y tenemos soluciones únicas que ofrecer.
Pero sí pertenecemos a la Tierra,
pertenecemos a la humanidad
y pertenecemos a las estrellas.
¿Qué habilidades van a necesitar
los niños de hoy
para guiar esta nave mañana?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Uf, ¡cómo se enredan los viejos!
(Risas)
Escuchad niños.
Dile a tu mamá y a tu papá:
no queremos más plásticos.
No queremos más azúcar.
Queremos un planeta limpio
y queremos un cuerpo sano.
Somos pájaros sin jaulas.
Gracias.
(Aplausos y ovaciones)